let's start with an overview what is the
problem you're trying to address and why
is this the right solution sure the
problem we're trying to address is that
the retirement landscape has changed
dramatically over the last 40 years in
the Ozzie and Harriet world people had a
defined benefit plan they worked 30
years at the same company they retired
with a pen a pension and a party and
they didn't have to worry about that
pension running dry because it was a
defined benefit pension for life now in
today's world of 401ks and IRAs the the
consumer has to take ownership over how
to spend their hard-earned money and
what we're doing today is making sure
that the regulatory landscape keeps up
with the changing retirement landscape
and making sure that the bedrock
principle of consumer protection which
is putting your customers first is put
in place in the retirement space and
that's what our rule is about it's about
saying that the the marketing slogans of
we put our clients first it's now it's
not only a marketing slogan now it's the
law so give us some sense of how broad
this regulation is how much money will
it affect how many people will have
direct well again this is a thirteen
trillion dollar market when you think
about IRAs and 401ks so it's not simply
my parents generation who's getting
ready to retire or has retired it's any
millennial who is you know yesterday's
yesterday's generation you worked one
job for 35 years
you know our millennial generation they
may work 35 jobs over 35 years and every
time they're rolling over from one job
to another and they they've accumulated
a 401k
that's an important point and they have
to understand that decisions they make
there can affect their long-term
retirement security so this affects
millions of Americans I mean the the
impact of conflicted advice
conservatively is estimated at about 17
billion dollars a year and that's a
conservative figure because it only
covers one segment of the market and so
anybody who is saving for retirement and
has a 401k or an IR
they just got a new tool to make sure
that they will be able to do a better
job saving right you also will affect
thousands maybe tens of thousands of
advisers and brokers across the country
have you done a cost-benefit analysis on
how much that will cost the industry to
provide this support
yes oppose what the benefit are yeah
it's part of our regulatory process and
you can get on our website and look at
the entire cost-benefit analysis and
I'll tell you the cost of doing the cost
of the status quo has been remarkably
burdensome for so many people and the
president this morning sent a letter to
the toefl Xin Illinois the toefl czar
regrettably a tragic example of what
happens when an advisor can put his own
self-interest over their best interest
they they worked hard played by the
rules had a nest egg at retirement of
six hundred and fifty thousand dollars
they went to their local bank because
mr. TOEFL had started to develop signs
of dementia could no longer manage his
money right and they were put into a
horrific product that was quote unquote
suitable for them but it was anything
but good for them and they ended up on a
horrific track and and that's not that
that's not who we are as a nation and
and again this is a simple principle you
know put your customers first people
like Jack Bogle who founded Vanguard and
has been a longtime supporter of our
rule said and he's right you know when
you put your customers first it's great
for your customers and it's great for
business and when you hear stories like
that no one can defend that that's
outrageous and it's a terribly sad but
there are also I'm sure thousands of
advisers we're doing it the right way
who are putting their customer centers
first so why is it the right way to do
this by a broad regulation that affects
everyone as opposed to just going after
the bad actors yeah and you know and and
and I really appreciate your question
because this is not a case about people
who have malice in their hearts and I've
said that repeatedly the advisers are
not bad people they you know I have
spoken to so many
and they're trying to do the right thing
this is a case about a system that is
structurally flawed the incentives are
not aligned in other words the consumers
best interest is not aligned with the
current incentives that result in
payments to brokers and so the the toefl
skates again run that was suitable they
didn't do anything wrong
legally but it's not right and that's
what we're fixing by making sure that
we've aligned right the incentive
structures mr. secretary you must have
considered the unintended consequences
that may come consequences such as some
people may actually lose access to
advice because it gets more difficult
and more expensive you may have
consolidation among the very largest of
the advisory groups as the small guys
get driven out because the compliance
costs what what is your assessment of
those unintended consequences well it's
you know the here's the good news on
that question and that's a very
important question we already have a
substantial subset of the market
including the adviser that my wife and I
use who act as fiduciaries okay so we
don't have to speculate about what
happens and and in my conversations and
later today we're doing an event and we
have a number of advisers who are going
to be there people who are already doing
what we are now requiring today and what
they tell me is this we have figured out
how to do good and do well it's a false
choice to suggest that the only way that
you can serve a small saver is by being
allowed to put your own interest ahead
of theirs and what they tell me most
frequently is tomm those companies who
say they're going to leave the market
for small savers give them my email give
them my phone number because I'm going
gangbusters and and you know the the
market rewards innovation it's
incredible to see the innovation already
occurring in this market to make advice
more accessible technology is our ally
and and and that's why I have great
confidence because people who are small
savers and middle class they shouldn't
have
a smaller set of consumer protections
that's not right
okay you can do good and do well here
okay that's the US second labor
secretary that's Tom Parris thank you
very much for joining us with repair